The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK.
So I don't know if everybody's
awake, but I will start.
So today, the topic is
actually Hamiltonian optics,
but we had some leftover
from last time, leakage.
So I'd like to go through
that very briefly.
And then I will handover
to Se Baek and Pepe,
who will give a
demonstration of aberrations
in sort of experimental
demonstration,
and also how optical
design software works.
And then we'll get
into Hamiltonian optics
the second hour, and
we'll see how far we go.
OK.
So last time we talked
about how many aberrations?
We talked about spherical,
coma, that's about it.
So we talked, actually,
about two aberrations.
And we said that there
is five of them--
the five so-called Seidel
aberrations or side order
aberrations.
And today, I'll cover
the other three.
So the first one in
line is astigmatism,
which is actually--
for me, at least, it is the
most difficult to visualize.
The best schematic I have seen
actually is in your textbook.
It's the middle
picture over here.
But before we get to that
and we see what happens
is, let's define to make sure
that we know the terminology.
So astigmatism happens--
look at the top left diagram.
Astigmatism happens
with an object point
that is off center.
And since it is off center,
imagine that there's
a fundamental asymmetry.
If you take the chief ray
that goes through the center
of the lens--
and again, here the assumption
is that the aperture
is at the lens itself.
So the chief ray goes to
the center of the lens.
So now you can
take two ray-- you
can think of two marginal rays.
One is the marginal
ray that goes
through the meridional plane.
So the meridional plane is
the one shown like this,
and the other is
the marginal ray
that goes through the
sagittal plane, perpendicular
to the meridional plane.
So astigmatism occurs
because the two--
now take cross-sections of
the rays in the two planes--
the sagittal and the
meridional plane.
That two ray bundles,
they do not necessarily
focus at the same place.
In the sagittal plane,
actually, if you
tried to visualize it
in the sagittal plane,
there is no difference
than normal incidence.
So you basically get--
so whereas in the meridional
plane, because you
are off-axis, you
have this property
that we discussed
before, that you'll
get different magnification at
different points in the field.
So as a result, these
two might actually
yield different focal distances.
So this is depicted here,
actually, where you're seeing--
it's actually a
pretty good diagram.
You can see the sagittal plane
and the meridional plane.
And you can see that the
sagittal plane actually
focuses out here.
It is F sub S for sagittal.
Whereas the meridional
plane focuses here.
It is called F sub
T for tangential.
So if an optical system is
subject to this problem,
we just call astigmatic.
The typical way that people
characterize astigmatism
is with a spoke wheel.
And most of you must
have taken eye exams.
They give you a
similar test, actually,
to test if your
eyes are astigmatic
and you need correction.
They show you something
like this, a spoke wheel.
And they ask you, basically, if
the spokes are simultaneously
in focus with the circle.
The outline circle.
So if the system
is astigmatic, then
as you move a piece of paper
along the optical axis,
you will see one of them
come to a focus first,
and the sagittal come
to the focus later.
OK.
So that's astigmatism.
I hear some voices,
but I think they're
from the next classroom,
not from Boston.
Did anybody say anything there?
I guess not.
OK.
A related aberration, which
has to do with the fact that--
well, let me say first.
So a related aberration is
called caricature of field.
This one is actually
easy to understand.
It says the following.
It says that if you derive the
imaging condition for a point
on-axis, then imagine
you go off-axis,
it says that the image
may not necessarily
focus on the same plane
as the image on-axis.
In fact, what this
aberration is about
is that the image actually comes
to focus on a curved surface.
Center of the optical axis.
Now, why do we care
about the plane?
Why do we want this
to be a plane here?
Well, in old
fashion cameras, one
used to put film at the
image plane of the camera.
So we have to be sure that
the entire image is focused
simultaneously on the film.
Nowadays, we don't use film.
We use a digital chip.
But in both cases, they're flat.
So curvature of field
is a problem then
because it says that actually
the off-axis image points will
be out of focus
because they will focus
in front of the final plane.
So these are the kind of
things that if you could,
for example, make a
curve chip surface,
you could solve it immediately.
All we have to do is match
the surface of the chip
to the surface of the
curvature of the field.
But in fact, actually,
people are trying
to do something like that.
There's a lot of work
on flexible electronics.
And that's one of
the motivations.
But it is not yet
widely available.
Nevertheless, there
is one condition
where the surfaces that the
field comes to focus actually
becomes flat.
This was derived
by a mathematician.
I don't know when.
I think it was in
the early 1900s.
His name is Petzval.
So this condition, it has a
more complicated expression.
But for two lenses, it works
out to something like this.
If the sum of these
quantities where
n1 is the index of
refraction of the lens.
And f1 is the focal length.
So it's a little
bit unusual now.
We multiply the focal length
by an index of refraction.
We've never done that before.
But this is what
this guy derived.
If they two sum up to
zero, these quantities
for a pair of lenses, then the
field of curvature vanishes.
And what is even more sort of
remarkable about this relation
is that it does not involve the
space in between the lenses.
No matter where they are, if
they satisfy this condition,
the field of curvature
will be eliminated.
And so for example,
if they are composed
of the same index of refraction,
then the index of refraction
also drops out of this equation.
And then you can treat them as
a composite, as a thick lens,
basically, which this is a
relationship that we already
derived for a composite element.
And you can make
sure that one of them
is the negative of the other so
that you can make this quantity
vanish.
That is, f1 is
equal to minus f2.
And then you can
find the focal length
from this equation over here.
So it's kind of cool because
it says that you can actually
eliminate--
if it is really
important to you,
you can eliminate this problem
by using the Petzval condition.
And again, there's a more
complicated condition
that applies to
multilens systems that
have more than two lenses.
But I didn't bother
to draw it here.
And what is even
more remarkable is
that the Petzval surface
and the field curvature
is also related to astigmatism.
So what you see in this plot
here, also from the textbook,
is the focal surfaces-- that is,
the surfaces in which different
points from a flat--
if you take a flat
object and you
take different points
along this object,
these three surfaces
are correspondingly
the tangential focus for
the astigmatic system,
the sagittal focus, and
finally the Petzval surface.
Yeah.
Let me go for [INAUDIBLE].
So what we discussed here is
actually the Petzval condition.
I haven't said yet what
is the Petzval surface.
So the Petzval surface
is the following.
It turns out that as
you change the stopping
and optical system--
that is, as you move
the stop in the
axial direction, you
can achieve the condition
where the tangential
and the sagittal
astigmatic focal
surfaces, they collapse
into one surface.
This surface is called
the Petzval surface,
not to be confused with
the Petzval condition,
even though, of course,
they are related.
So what you see
here is basically,
as you move the stop
in an optical system--
this is borrowed from
another textbook, not from--
I should have
recorded, actually.
This is from Jenkins and
White, Fundamentals of Optics.
So as you move the stop,
you can find the situation
where the two surfaces coincide,
and that is the Petzval surface
of the system.
And of course, this one does not
satisfy the Petzval condition
because the Petzval
surface is curved.
If I could somehow satisfy
both the Petzval condition
and collapse that to surfaces--
tangential and sagittal--
onto the Petzval, then I
would have a flat system
with a flat field, which would
also be free of astigmatism.
So obviously we cannot get
into too much detail about this
without becoming quantitative.
And this is quite difficult
to deal with algebra,
so I'm just being descriptive.
And you will see some
of this in action
when Se Baek does the demo of
the software in a little bit.
And the light distortion
that I will discuss
has to do with something
slightly different.
So the field of curvature
occurs and astigmatism
occurs because if you take
object points off-axis,
they fail to focus
at the same plane.
They focus at different planes
and on different surfaces,
the sagittal and tangential.
The distortion
occurs because even
if you manage to
focus at one plane,
the magnification is different.
The magnification-- and this you
can see very easily, actually,
just looking at this
diagram over here.
If you take the on-axis point,
the imaging and condition
of the magnification are
given by these distances.
For example, the
lateral magnification
is the ratio of this
distance to this distance.
But what about this point now?
For this point, the
lateral magnification
will be the ratio of this
distance to this distance.
And for those of
you in Boston, I'm
pointing out to the
tilted chief ray.
So I have to
measure the distance
from the lens on the chief ray.
And you can see very
easily that this length is
different than the
length of the chief ray
for the on-axis point.
So because of that, the
magnification on-axis
is different than the
magnification off-axis.
Therefore, if I attempt
to image a checkerboard,
like this, if the
magnification is different,
I will see this sort of--
I don't want to use
the word "distorted."
You will see this
sort of altered--
let's say altered-- image.
And this is the
definition of distortion.
So in optics we have
to be a little careful.
Distortion, colloquially,
means everything.
All of the stuff that
I described before.
In everyday English, you
can call them distortions.
Well, in optics, in
professional optics,
when we mention distortion, we
automatically mean this one.
So we have to be careful
not to use the word
"distortion" in the
colloquial sense
because it is reserved
to mean exactly that.
And I guess it has two forms.
It can be of this type,
where the magnification is
higher off-axis.
That is called pincushion.
Or lower, that is called barrel.
And they believe, in this case,
the top one will give rise
to barrel because in this
case, because the stop is here,
the aperture stop is here, the
chief ray on the object side
becomes longer off-axis.
Now, if you recall,
the magnification
is the lateral
magnification equals
S on the image side over S on
the object side with a minus
sign.
But the minus is
irrelevant here.
So since I made--
so in this case, S
on the image side
is approximately
the same as on-axis.
But S on the object
side became longer
by putting the stop here.
So therefore, I get a lower
magnification off-axis.
Therefore, I get this
type of distortion.
If I put the stop
on the other side,
then it is the opposite case.
Now I make this length longer.
Therefore, I get
pincushion distortion.
And of course, the way to
eliminate distortion altogether
is to make the system like this.
This is actually a
telecentric system.
And to make sure that
the stop is exactly
at the center of the system.
And also-- yes.
And so if you do
that, then basically
a little bit of thought will
convince you that in this case
the variation between this
length is actually very small.
So therefore, there
is some distortion,
but it is high order.
The third order distortion is
completely eliminated here.
So you basically get a
distortion-free image.
OK.
So before I turn over
to Se Baek and Pepe,
last time I mentioned caustics.
So I would like to
show what caustics are.
So this is actually from the
last page of today's notes,
which I haven't done yet.
And the details here
are not very important.
By the end of the
lecture today, you
will know what
has happened here.
This is a special type of lens
called a gradient index lens.
And I simulated it with
off-axis incidence.
So therefore, in this
case, we have coma.
So if you look at the ray, these
are ray traces of this lens.
For now, please accepted the
fact that the rays are curved.
But what I wanted
to show you here,
what is the caustic that I
mentioned in the last lecture.
You can see that in the
bottom side of this diagram
that ray paths, they kind
of collapse onto each other.
So you see that the rays
are relatively uniformly
distributed up to this
point approximately.
Over here, they begin to
accumulate near one side.
So what you would
expect in this case,
if you put a piece
of paper here,
is you would expect very
strong light intensity
near the bottom of the beam.
So that is what
we call a caustic.
And I think in the examples
that the guys will show you
in the demo, you will also
see some caustics form
in real life.
But this is what I was
trying to describe last time.
OK.
So Pepe and Se
Baek, I don't know
if you guys are ready but--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK.
PROFESSOR: Can you
help me with that.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Take it away.
PROFESSOR: So this is a similar
demo to the one that we showed.
Now we're going to focus
on a different thing
of the aberrations that
we've been learning.
So so far we've seen two type
of aberrations in the system
that we can identify
very easily.
But first, let me
describe the components.
So can you go back here.
So for this one here we
start with a laser, as usual.
And now we know that we have
a collimating system so used
to condition the light and make
a nice plane wave at the output
here.
And then this plane wave
illuminates these lens,
which is a cylindrical
lens, shown here.
And then we are just looking
at the rays going on.
And this is for a green laser.
It's a wavelength
of 532 nanometers.
So now let's think what's
happening, actually.
So we can reduce exposure.
OK.
So we can see at this point
how the rays start converging.
But it's a bit hard to
see here, but they do not
focus in a tight point.
They actually focus
at different points.
And as we'll see
in the software,
this is basically the
experimental version
of a spherical aberration
that we can see.
And in this case, I'm
illuminating the lens
with an on-axis plane wave.
So therefore, we can
see its condition.
Now let's try to look
at the case of coma
as seen from the top.
So what I'm doing is that
I'm rotating the lens.
And then we can see
how the rays start
forming an asymmetric pattern.
And let me try to get
this closer together.
So now for this
off-axis plane wave,
we see that that's some of
the rays go straight through
and some of the rays form these
caustics here that we just
mentioned--
George mentioned in the slides.
If we were to put a page
perpendicular to this one
that I have here, which is
hard because we need actually
a camera in order to show
you that with very, very
tiny pixels because the
actual point produces
or the focus produced by this
lens would be very small.
But if we do that, we
would see the comma shape
that we described.
And we're actually going to see
that in the simulation software
that we're going to show later.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Pepe?
PROFESSOR: Yep?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Is it possible to put
the other business
card-- can you
put the back of the
business card there?
PROFESSOR: You're
saying perpendicular?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: You don't
see anything, George.
This is a cylindrical lens.
This is cylindrical.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And you see what I'm saying?
These are cylindrical lens.
And even with a CCD,
it's very, very small.
You would need something, in
order to measure it accurately,
something that is called a
Foucault knife edge test,
for example, where you actually
can measure what is called
the point spread function.
And we're going to learn that
in the next part of the course.
All right.
So let me show you another
type of aberration.
Now imaging our transparency.
In this case, I just
have a white light source
that is illuminating this
object, which is just
a transparency with some GRIN.
In this case, it's going to be
just the GRIN that George was
showing that is regular GRIN.
And I have a single lens here.
It's a spherical lens, biconvex,
with a short focal length.
So therefore, the
curvature is pretty high,
and we expect to have
a lot of aberrations.
But the one that we're
going to see here--
we can decrease
exposure-- we're going
to see the evidence
of distortion,
the aberration of distortion.
And as you can see here--
let's just focus in.
You see how the lines--
similar to the slide
that George just showed,
the lines are actually
curved by this lens.
Although these are supposed
to be straight lines,
they are curved.
Let me just magnify
a little bit this.
There you go.
Increase.
Now if we were to replace
these with another lens--
so for example, this one that
has a longer focal length--
the radius of
curvature is larger.
So it's basically not
as curved as this one.
And we're trying to do the same.
Now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use this lens to image
my transparency.
Now we can see how the lines
look much more straight.
That distortion
aberration got reduced.
So what type of aberration
did you guys see?
It was pincushions
or barrel aberration,
the one that you saw before?
I'm going to put it again
while you guys think.
Which one is this?
I can hear.
Just press the button, please.
AUDIENCE: Pincushion?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
We see the evidence of the
magnification of the lenses.
It's maybe hard for
you being able to see.
But here, the lines basically
get curved to outside.
So in the break, if you guys
want to come on and just
play with the demo and
change the focal length
and see where the images get
formed, and also this one here,
you're welcome to do so.
Now we're going to switch
to our numerical software
to show how we actually
deal with these in practice
to optimize an imaging system.
SE BAEK OH: OK.
So people, before we move
on to next topic, which
is a GRIN medium and
Hamiltonian optics,
we want to show how we
actually build or design
the actual imaging optical
system in practice.
Of course, so far we
learn a lot of stuff.
The Snell's law, and
reflection and refraction,
and the lens maker's
law, and paraxial optics,
and blah, blah, blah.
But in real life, we usually
use a computer software.
So just to give you an
example, since most of you
are mechanical engineer,
including myself.
So let's think about this.
If you want to build some
toy or some mechanical model
for your bike or car
or toy, what do you do
is you start with
sketching by hand.
So make the conceptual model.
And then you go to computer.
Use the CAD program.
So your build the
2D or 3D model.
And if you have
multiple element,
you can even assembly,
in SolidWorks.
And you can export the 3D model.
And if your system is
complicated enough,
you can also use
finite element model
to analyze the stress or strain
or the temperature variations,
blah, blah, blah.
Same idea.
You start with the conceptual
model by drawing a few rays.
And then you apply lens law
and the 1 over object distance
plus 1 over image distance
should be 1 over f.
And sometime you only
use the [INAUDIBLE]..
But after that
you go to computer
and use probably one of these
commercialized software, which
is Code V. So it's not
V. It's a Roman number.
So Code V or ZEMAX and Oslo.
So the Code V and ZEMAX, they
are industrial standards.
And they are pretty
much the same.
So if you can
handle one of these,
then it's very easy to do--
easy to use the other one.
So essentially what it does
is it draws some rays for you
but very fast, and
it's automated fashion.
Because if you have CAD
program, you can use actually
do this ray tracing.
So you just draw a ray.
And whenever you
meet the interface,
you complete the incident
angle to the surface normal
and apply the Snell's law
and compute refraction angle
and do the same thing.
But it's very
complicated, especially
you have the 3D model.
So this program
does that for you.
And it actually has
very different method
to do the ray tracing.
So first of all it's just--
actually, we learn the
ray transfer matrices.
So it does ray tracing based
on the paraxial region.
But probably one of the reasons
that we use the software.
It does the real ray tracing.
Just as I described,
it just trace every ray
based on Snell's law.
And you can use it--
and actually, it also has
many built-in features
to analyze performance
of optical system,
like aberration.
So we learn about the five
geometric aberrations.
You can analyze it.
And also, point spread
function or spot
diagram, which means if you have
ideal imaging system and lets
say we have point
object, the images
should be also infinitely
small point, assuming
that they are conjugated.
But in real life, it
never be like this
because you always have the
finite size of focused image.
So point spread
function or spot diagram
tells you how big is your
focus at the image plane.
And it also analyze MTF or OTF,
which is frequency analysis.
We cover later of the course.
And probably--
actually, another reason
that we have to
use this software
is to optimize the
optical system.
I prepared some
examples, so we will see.
So this is the--
so we are using the ZEMAX.
Just the one of the
industry's standard.
And if you open
the ZEMAX in this,
we have this table, which
basically are lens data editor.
So filling in this
table means you
specify your optical system.
I'll describe how to do it.
But once you have this--
once you fill in
this table, then you
can analyze very
different stuff.
So for example, it shows the
actual layout of a system,
like this one.
This 2D layout.
And it even made the 3D
model for you, like this one.
So it can check the actual
shape of the system.
So this is called [INAUDIBLE].
So actually, the horizontal axis
is actually your pupil plane,
and vertical axis is deviation
of the ray at the image plane.
So if you have--
so if your system
is aberration free,
then these lines should
be just horizontal here
because all the rays
meet at the point.
But this is practical system so
you have the deviation, which
means you have aberration.
And these guys are spot diagram.
So if you have point object
in your object space,
then you'll probably
get this kind of focus
at your image plane.
And this is same thing but
for different wavelengths
because the glass
is dispersive, which
means the refractive
index is also
a function of the wavelength.
So if you change the wavelength,
then the shape of these spots
also change.
So it analyzed this
dispersive property.
OK.
So let me explain how to
fit into those tables.
So let's say we have
this two lens system.
So what you do is you
just decompose your system
to multiple surface.
So for example, here
I have the object.
So this is by
default surface zero.
And the first surface
should be the front surface
of the first lens here.
And surface two is the back
surface of the first lens.
And the surface three
is the front surface
of the second lens,
and so on and so forth.
So in the table we have the
different-- the multiple roles.
So each role represent
the one surface.
And the radius means the radius
curvature of the surface.
So for example, here,
since this object is flat,
the radius curvature
is infinity.
And thickness is the
distance from the surface
to the next surface.
So in this case, d0 is
the distance from here
to the first lens.
And in some case, if you deal
with the infinite conjugate,
like telescope, then
this d0 could be infinite
because your object
is at infinity.
And at the surface one,
I have the lens which
has the radius curvature R1.
So I have R1.
And thickness d1 represent the
thickness of the actual length
from here to here.
And after the surface
one, I have the glass.
So I just can specify the type
of glass, which is BK7 here.
This is the most
common optical glass.
And you just keep
repeating this one.
So once you have this
and you have the--
you just fill in the
table in the ZEMAX.
And there are also other
parameters you have to specify.
So as I said, the wavelength.
And you also need to choose
the field parameter, which
basically this means
object information.
So if your object is
in finite distance,
then field means object
height or size of your object,
or if it is infinite, you
can set the incident angle
to the system, just
like the telescope.
So first example I
prepare is actually
the example the lecture three.
So we had the two lens.
Both of them have the focal
length of 10 here and here.
And if you went
through the derivation,
we had the several
different ways to derive.
But the image distance--
actually, it's
not image distance.
The imaging is located
at 30 millimeter
behind the second length,
and the lateral magnification
was negative 4.
And also, if you did the
wavelength of matrices,
then effective focal length was
20 over 3, which is about 7.
And the front focal length
and back focal length
was 10 over 3.
So about 3, right?
So in ZEMAX, I already
filled in the table.
So this is the how
the system looks like.
I have the object here,
and I have the image here.
And if you analyze
the system, then it
gives you all the
specifications here.
So here, the effective
focal length is 6-point--
I don't know you can see, but
the effective focal length
is 6.92.
So about 7.
So we have a good
agreement here.
And the back focal
length is about 3.05.
So about 3.
And the paraxial
magnification is negative 4.8.
So we have a slightly bigger
magnification in real system,
and so on and so forth.
And also, I put the
aperture stuff here.
So you can compute
the diameter--
the size and position of the
entrance pupil and exit pupil
as well.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Se Baek?
SE BAEK OH: Yes?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: I think
the reason for the discrepancy
is that the lenses have finite
thickness in your model, right?
SE BAEK OH: Yes.
So in real model, as you
can see in the layout,
this is not in length.
And I just put the
brief numbers--
the radius of the lens.
So I just put the 10.5.
And the thickness of the lens
in 1 millimeter in this case.
So it's not the real length.
So it gives you slightly
different numbers.
And the next example is actually
the Hubble Space Telescope.
So Professor
Barbastathis already
mentioned the last lecture
about this telescope.
So actually, NASA realized after
they launched this telescope
and find out the image is not
good as it's supposed to be.
And they form a committee to
investigate what's the problem.
And they eventually figured
out, and they fix it.
But let's just start
with the structure here.
So this is a typical
classic type telescope.
We have two mirrors.
So one is primary
mirror, which is
a concave hyperboloid
mirror, and we
have the secondary mirror, which
is convex hyperboloidal mirror.
And the size of the mirror, the
diameter is about 2.4 meters.
The primary mirror.
And the second one is about,
I guess, 60 centimeters or so.
And the distance between these
two mirror was 4.94 meters.
So it's a huge telescope.
And after extensive
investigation,
the problem was, actually, the
shape of the primary mirror
is not same as the
intended shape.
So the overall shape--
I mean, the curvature
of the mirror
was slightly different
than the design.
And it turns out
that even though--
actually, the diameter of this
primary lens is 2.4 meter.
But at the edge, the
difference between the design
and the actual shape
was only 4 micrometer.
So it's very small, the
physical difference.
So just give you an idea.
So the black hair,
like the Asians,
like myself, the diameter
of the thick hair
is about 100 micrometer.
So 4 micrometer is
very, very small
distance compared
to the diameter.
But in general, it introduced
a huge speckle aberration,
which means ideally you have--
all these incoming rays
should meet at one point,
but it has a different
extended focal point.
So the effect was
too catastrophic.
So the image of the galaxy
it looked like this.
But after they fix,
So does anyone know how
NASA fixed this problem?
The telescope was
already in orbit,
so you cannot take it
back to the ground.
And to fabricate another big
mirror also need huge resource.
So how can you fix?
Yeah.
So actually what they did is--
this is huge telescope.
And they had a focal point.
And they have different
cameras, because you
deal with different spectrum,
like visible or the IR or UV.
And what they did, actually--
and all these cameras
show the same focal plane.
So what they did, they actually
sacrificed another camera
and put another
mirror system here
to introduce this
speckle aberration
but in opposite fashion.
So they kind of canceled
the speckle aberration.
So I prepared an example in
ZEMAX with the real parameter.
So this is the intended design
of the Hubble Space Telescope.
And as you can see,
the surface number two
and surface number
three, they are
primary and secondary mirror.
And this is
hyperboloidal mirror.
So you have-- we have here.
So conic coefficient.
And this is the simulation
result if you have--
simulation result
of image if you
have the letter F. But
due to the manufacturing
process, this conic
coefficient was not this one.
So actually it was
negative 1.02324.
So overall shape it
doesn't change that much.
But the image analysis
looks very blurred.
So that's why we had the
very blurred image of galaxy.
And that's why you need to
deal with all these aberration
with this computer software
because you can analyze
easily and compensate easily.
OK.
So last example is optimization.
So for example, let's
think about this one.
I want to design some
optical system which
has three lenses here.
So these two positive lens
is made by crown glass,
and this negative lens
is actually flint glass.
And if you want to
design this one,
then you have many
parameters you can tune.
So the radius curvature
of each length--
so R1/R2, R3/R4, and R5/R6.
And also the thickness of the
lens, and also the distance
between the lenses.
So we have another
six parameters here.
So you have total 12
parameters you can choose.
And it's hard to find the best
parameter because you need
some specification to satisfy.
So what you do is you can just
run the optimization routine
here.
So first process-- first
procedure is select variable.
As I just described,
you can tune the radius
of curvature of the
lens and the thickness
and the distance between lenses.
So you want to choose the
variable you can tune.
And this column, you
define the merit function,
or sometimes it is called object
function or cross function.
Basically, you just select
what you want to minimize.
For example, you
want to minimize
some speckle aberration
for given object point,
or maybe you can
minimize a spot diagram,
like size or focus for
different field points.
And also, you can add some
constraint, like your total--
physical system
should be like this.
It cannot longer than
certain distance.
Or the thickness of the
lens can be constrained due
to the manufacturing process.
So you can add some constraints.
And then what you do is compute
the value of merit function
with the different
combination of the parameter.
And this is the automated--
this is iterative process
so ZEMAX can do it for you.
So this is the
layout of the system.
I start with just
three each value--
I just choose the
random value of this--
I mean, there's 12 values here.
So we have the
three lenses here.
And parameter with
the [INAUDIBLE],,
they are variables.
So we have the 12
variables here.
And this is the result
of the aberration
at the initial state.
And the spot diagram
through the focus.
So as the bottom left figure,
I have four different incident
angles.
So 1, 2, 3, 4.
The different colors here.
So these four rows
in spot diagram
means they're corresponding to
this different incident angle.
And these five column means
I had five different defocus.
So center one is focused,
and they are slightly
defocused in front or back.
I also have the spot diagram
with different wavelength.
So this one is
about 500 nanometer.
And it's about 480 nanometer.
I guess this one is 550 or so.
50 or so.
And this is merit function.
I already defined
the merit function.
Actually, I used the default
merit function in this case.
So there are many, many
different parameter
you can tune, but
the essence is you
want to minimize some
aberration at the image plane.
So I'm going to run this
optimization with the auto
update.
So you're going to see the
actual shape of this analysis
for every iteration.
So we start with this situation,
and I run 50 cycles here.
So every iteration
is update the system.
And it actually improve
the performance of system.
So yeah.
So after 50 iterations,
this focus is much nicer.
Focus is much nicer.
And it doesn't change that much.
But actually, the
scales are different.
So actually it improved a lot.
So after this is
optimized-- so this
is what usually
optical engineers
do in industry when you want
to design some optical system.
But is this the best design?
I mean, can you say this
is this the best design?
Probably not because it's
just one of the minimum.
It can be just global minimum.
So it's kind of sensitive to
initial value or constraint
or whatever.
And also, there are
many, many issues--
I mean practical issues--
we have to consider.
For example, in this case,
let's see this third lens.
The last lens.
The radius of curvature of
this lens is 60.8 on this one.
And the second radius
is negative 68.3.
So they are very
similar, which means
it looks like convex lens.
But they are very deep.
They are slightly different,
but they are not same.
So if you're on an
assembly system,
then you need to figure out
which surfaces from surfaces
shown is the back surface.
But it's very similar, so
it's hard to figure out.
So sometimes you
need to consider
many, many practical issues
because in this case,
it's not good design
because they are so similar.
You better have
the plane of convex
to figure out which
surface is front
and which surface back surface.
So ZEMAX does that for you.
I mean, the optimization.
But you need to
interpret the result,
and you need to take into
account many practical issues.
So basically, which
means it means nothing.
So that's why we learn
many, many different things.
I mean, the geometrical optics,
you need to interpret it.
And you need the
experience and insight.
Yeah.
That's what I prepared today.
PROFESSOR: The last example
that we're going to show
is on a gradient
refractive index lens.
So these are a very
interesting type of lenses.
I have this microphone here.
Very interesting type of lenses
because the index of refraction
as opposed to normal lenses
that you're familiar with
and we've been showing over
and over, which is just
a piece of glass with a
fixed index of refraction,
in this case, as
we've been mentioning,
the index of refraction changes
as a function, in this case,
of radius.
So the lens itself, it
looks like this rod here.
So this is a 3D model.
Just like a cylinder of glass.
But its properties, or
its optical properties,
especially a refractive index,
as you can see, changes.
And in this case, commercially
available green lenses,
the way they're
manufactured, they're
constrained to be with a
parabolic index of refraction
variation.
So at the center-- so this is
basically distance from the--
radial distance is at
the center of the lens.
Optical axis.
And this as we
propagate to one--
as we move to one of the
extremes of the lens.
And we see that we have the
highest index of refraction
at the center.
And then the case
parabolically to the sides.
And if you can notice here the
variation from top to bottom
is maybe hard to read.
But it's very, very small.
So it goes from something
like 1.6 to 1.59
or something like that.
So it's very, very small,
the index variation.
However, that is enough
to guide the light
and cause the rays to bend.
So one thing that
we're going to see here
is that Snell's law is basically
applied in a little bit
different way.
Before, we're interested
in curved surfaces.
And a ray hitting a
given curved surface
will bend accordingly
to Snell's law
and the index of refraction.
In this case, you see that the
faces of the lens to both sides
are flat.
So if the index of these
was basically uniform,
the plane wave would just go
straight through like a piece
of glass, like in a window.
But the fact that this has a
parabolic index of refraction,
then it makes these
rays to smoothly
be guided and bent
towards a focus.
In this case,
on-axis or off-axis.
This is a 10 degree off-axis
plane wave incidence.
So what is the nice
thing about these things?
It's that instead
of only using, you
can think of the refractive
power of these two surfaces.
This type of lens
uses the entire volume
of the lens to guide the rays.
So therefore, if I
put a screen here and
see the intersections of all
these rays in that screen--
this is the spot diagram
that we've been seeing also
in the other ones--
we see that for
the on-axis point,
we have a tight focus,
which typically is smaller.
In this case, the focal length,
the effective focal length
of this system is very small.
So if you try to do this
with a normal refractive
lens with curved
surfaces, you would
need to have a really,
really curved lens.
And as we know from the demos
and from the discussions,
those type of lenses
will be really aberrated.
However, these, even though
it has a shorter focal length,
it still focuses into
a very tight focus
because it uses, as I
said, the entire volume.
Now here, this is
the example of coma.
So if I actually show--
I can even focus a little bit
into how the rays are coming.
And we see the similar caustics
that you saw in the demo
and in the slides before.
But if we put a
screen here, this
is the actual shape of the
rays intersecting that plane.
So these two are the
circles of confusion.
And just to give
you a preview, this
is basically for
the on-axis point.
So this is what
geometrical optics predict.
The bottom one.
So the geometrical
optics predict just how
rays intersect a given plane.
It doesn't take into
account diffraction
that we're going to learn in
the next part of the course.
However, diffraction is very
important in optical system
because it regulates resolution.
And many of you have been
asking about numerical aperture
and how that depends
on resolution
and what happens changing the
aperture stop and so on and so
forth.
Well, this is also very related
to this point spread function
that you can see here.
And as you can see,
it's a bright spot,
and then there's
concentric rings
which is the way you
can see the diffraction
effect of that point.
So this is geometrical version.
This is the diffraction version
or the more realistic version
of how light would diffract.
And in order to
compute this, we'll
basically need the
math and the tools
that we're going to learn in
the second part of the course.
But this is just giving you the
type of science and analysis
that we could do
in this software.
So any questions before--
because we're going to
break, right, George?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Any questions
before the break?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: I
think it's time to continue.
Before I move on, are
there any questions about--
I don't know.
About anything.
About the homeworks, about
the lectures, about imaging,
about focusing?
A bit of a milestone, I guess.
I don't believe in quizzes.
Actually, I hate giving exams.
But I have to produce grades.
The register asks for grades.
So the accepted, I guess,
established way is with exams.
But anyway.
And I also hate reviews
because of the same reason
because a review
suggests somehow
that the quiz is important.
Of course, the quiz
is not important
except for the register.
The only significance,
perhaps, exams
have is that they really
force you to study.
I mean, if you didn't have
an exam, then you would say,
well, maybe I'll study later.
Maybe I will study
in the summer.
When I go out water
skiing, I can study optics
while I water ski.
But anyway.
So I try to--
in my classes, I try
to de-emphasize exams
as much as possible.
And the assumption is that
if throughout the course
of the class you have
learned the material,
then you will do
well in the exam.
Whereas to do the
opposite, to try
to satisfy the needs of the exam
is very limited because then,
what you get out of it?
You're wasting your time.
So that's why I try
to not mention exams.
As far as I can help it,
I try not to mention them.
But I know--
I've been a student also.
At the time I would also be
very worried about exams.
Anyway.
So this is the time.
Is there any sort of--
whatever.
Review questions or--
OK.
I'm going to count
to from 3 down.
3, 2, how they do
in auctions, 1.
You can still interrupt.
Also, we have the class forum.
I mean the online chat room
or whatever it's called.
The forum the call it.
So of course, you can
post questions there.
I will be diligently checking.
Also, I sent an
announcement by email.
You may have not seen it yet.
But we've posted
some solved problems.
Actually, the problems have
been posted since Monday.
So the problems are solved.
So you don't really
have to-- so this
is the homework for next week.
You don't have to actually turn
in the homework on the quiz
day.
That would have been cruel.
But we actually gave you
some solved problems.
So you can go over them.
And of course the
recommendation is
to really pretend that you
don't have the solution.
Try to solve it yourself.
And then check it--
check your solution
against ours.
And of course, you don't have
to turn in your solution.
And I'll stop talking
about the exam
now, unless someone has
a question now or later.
So Pepe already
gave an introduction
to the topic of gradient
index or GRIN optics.
And he mentioned that the
motivation is basically
that if you can focus
the light by using
a non-uniform material,
a material whose
index of refraction is variable,
perhaps you can get away
by also using a material
whose surface is flat.
So you don't have to use this
awkward spherical shape that we
know from everyday optics.
Maybe you can have
something that
looks like a slab or a plate.
And nevertheless, this
flat-looking plate
might have the ability
to focus light.
So the way you can
do-- first of all,
can you do this kind of thing?
Can you make an element with
variable index or the fraction.
So there's two-- well,
there's many ways.
But in industry, in
manufacturing practices,
there's two ways
that are being used.
And I will describe them.
One is called ion exchange.
And what they do is
they take a glass rod,
which is doped with a
certain kind of ions--
typically, they use
sodium in the glass rod.
Then they have the glass meld
at the very high temperature,
of course, with a
different kind of ion.
Typically lithium.
And what happens is they
slowly dip the glass rod
into the glass meld.
And over a period of several
hours, what's happens
is the lithium ions, they kick
out some of the sodium ions
from the glass rod.
They basically
penetrate the rod,
and they kick out some
of the sodium ions.
But of course, the
index of refraction
depends on what kind of ions
you have inside of the glass.
And also, because the
ions, they propagate
at a finite speed,
what will happen
here is in the exterior
of the glass rod,
you get a lot of ion exchange.
So the index changes a lot.
But near the center, if
you get your timing right,
near the center you don't
get any exchange at all.
So you basically have--
in the center you
only have sodium ions.
Near the exterior to give
both sodium and lithium.
So you can get a situation
where the index of refraction
is different in the center
than it is at the edge.
And then what they
do, of course,
is after they
finish this process,
they chop this glass
rod into slabs.
And then each one of those
slabs is to become a GRIN lens.
And as I said before,
they do it typically
so that the index is
higher in the center
and lower at the edges.
So this kind of thing I
will do in detail later.
But if you look at
it in cross-section,
it focuses like so
if you illuminate it
with parallel bundle of rays.
You can think of the
index of refraction
as an attraction
of sorts for rays.
So the ray that enters at
the lower index, it gets
attracted by the high index.
It bends.
And as a result, by the
time the rays come out,
they actually come out
as a focusing bundle.
So you can use this
element to focus light.
So just like a lens, but
it has a flat surface.
And because the ionic change
is actually diffusion-driven--
I don't want to go into the
mathematics of diffusion.
But it turns out that if you get
the specific form of the index
of refraction that
you get in this case,
it's quadratic or parabolic.
So it is maximum in the center.
And then it drops
as the square--
as the radius square, where r
is the radius in the slab times
some coefficient alpha.
And I will show in a second
that this coefficient alpha
and the thickness of the
lens, the product of the two
actually specifies
the focal length.
So this looks like
a funny formula.
But if you think
about it, alpha must
have dimensions that
are inverse distance
square so that the product
alpha times r squared
is non-dimensional.
And d is distance.
So therefore, the units
here are distance.
So indeed, the quantity
over there is the distance.
It is the focal length.
So let's see now why
this is the case.
So I guess we've done
it several times.
So you must be
tired of it by now.
I just lost my--
oh, maybe I'll use
the-- oh, thanks.
I also must not forget this.
OK.
So in typical fashion, we
will use Fermat's principle
in order to calculate
what is happening here.
So Fermat says that if you--
here is my element.
And I have two rays that
both started at infinity.
So the rays share their
origin, the starting point.
And then my desire here,
my intended outcome,
is that these two rays
meet because I want
the element to focus the light.
So Fermat says that the optical
path length here on-axis
and the optical path
length out here off-axis,
they must be equal.
Because the rays started
at the same point,
they end up at the same point,
the optical path lengths
must be equal.
So what is the
optical path length?
So this derivation here is very
highly handwaving and very,
very inaccurate.
But bear with me.
In the next half
hour, I will tell you
how this calculation
can be done exactly.
But for now, this is kind
of an interesting way
to think about GRIN,
so we'll do it anyway.
It's also in the book.
So you don't really have
to copy my derivation here.
You already have
it in two places.
One is in the book, and
the other is the notes.
So maybe you can just
look at it and don't
bother to write it down.
So let's compare the two rays.
Let's compare the on-axis ray,
which basically goes straight.
This is the optical axis.
And the off-axis ray, which
as Pepe already mentioned,
the off-axis ray will actually
do something like this.
It will bend.
And then, of course, after
it comes out in free space,
it will go straight.
We know that for sure.
But inside the gradient index
medium, the ray will bend.
It will follow a continuous
kind of trajectory.
This is also counterintuitive
because in our experience
light rays go straight.
But such is life.
Physics sometimes have
unexpected outcomes.
If you put a ray in a
gradient index medium,
indeed it will bend onto
a curved trajectory.
So let's put some notation here.
So we'll call this r.
This is the radial direction.
We'll call this d.
This is the thickness
of the GRIN.
We'll call this f.
This is the focal length.
And for the sake
of this derivation,
let me actually redraw it.
I will redraw it.
Forgive me.
I just want to emphasize
this caricature.
So we'll actually
neglect this distance.
This space over there, I
will pretend it's not there.
And this is consistent with
a paraxial approximation.
Here is r, here is d
again, and here is f.
And that's the optical axis.
OK.
So well, let's do, first
of all, the optical path
length for the on-axis ray.
The optical path
length equals the index
times the distance integrated
over the path of the ray.
So this would equal the
index at radius equal 0.
That is the index over
here at the center
of the lens times the
thickness of the lens
plus the focal length.
So of course, outside the lens,
the index we assume to be 1.
You can have an imaginary lens,
but let's not do that now.
So this is where it comes from.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: According
to Fermat's principle,
it says that the ray
travels in such a way
that it tries to
minimize the path.
So why does the ray goes from
lower index to higher index?
Means if it goes into
higher index material,
actually it is increasing
its optical path length?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Ah.
But it will bend.
That's what Snell says.
It will bend so that the total
path length actually decreases.
Did I answer your question or
did you have something else?
AUDIENCE: I think--
well, I don't know,
but maybe the answer to your
question is that although--
I think what he says is
that it will actually
travel through a longer
optical path in the medium
because it goes into
the bigger index.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Ah.
OK.
I see.
AUDIENCE: But I think
that's counteracted
by the extra that would be
outside, isn't it, in the air,
I think.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
And you will see that
in the derivation.
Because it will have to
go through this hypotenuse
over here, it will
actually-- yeah.
So the overall path
is actually minimized.
And this is the only
way it can be minimized.
OK.
So lo and behold, then,
let's do what you just said.
So what about the
ray that arrives
at the higher elevation?
So here I'm going
to cheat big time.
I'm going to pretend
that all of this--
the ray bends, of course.
But I'm going to pretend that
throughout all this travel
here, the ray sees the
same index of refraction.
This is a gross approximation,
but I will do it.
So therefore, this is--
so n0, another name for it is--
it is also equal to n max.
The optical part for
n1 will be equal n max.
1 minus alpha r
square over 2, which
is the index of refraction
at the elevated position.
And then, as you
pointed out, it will
go through this increased
distance, which is
the hypotenuse of the triangle.
So it is really r
squared plus f squared.
So again, I pretended that
this r and this r are the same.
I want to emphasize that
this is an approximation.
I'm cheating.
OK.
The next is actually
easier from now on.
All I'm going to do-- and
the reason I'm going to do it
is to remind you.
I'm going to do the paraxial
approximation, which basically
says that r is much less than f.
So that means that square
root can be written as--
I pull the f outside.
1 plus r square over f
square approximately equal f1
plus r square over 2f square.
And this is actually equal
to f plus r square over 2f.
So now let's write down
Fermat's principle.
Fermat says that OPL 0
must be equal to OPL 1.
So OPL 0 was n max
times d plus f.
And OPL 1 was--
again, if you look at
it from this equation,
OPL 1 was this expression
times d, of course.
I forgot to put the d here.
Times this distance.
So it is equal to n max 1 minus
alpha r square over 2 times
d plus f plus--
what was it-- r square over 2f.
Now a number of
things will cancel.
This will eat this one.
And all that is left is
that n max times alpha r
square over 2d with a minus sign
plus r square over 2f equals 0.
And now we can see that
the quadratic dependence
for the index of
refraction that we draw
is convenient because the
same quadratic came out
of the paraxial approximation
of the square root.
So I can just cancel
the two quadratics.
And the twos also cancel.
And I get that f
equals the inverse
of all of that, 1 over n
max times alpha times d.
This is how we find the
focal length of the GRIN.
So this appears a little bit
mysterious what happened here.
How did I pull this
out of the hat?
Well, what it really means--
the fact that this
has a solution
means that this element
actually succeeds in focusing.
What I mean is the following.
Suppose that what came
out of this equation
was not the nice quadratic
that canceled, but suppose
I got something like this.
Suppose I got minus n max
alpha r cube, for example,
over 2 times d plus r
square over 2f equals 0.
Well, if this is what I had
gotten, I'm out of luck.
This is not a proper lens.
So what I'm trying
to say is suppose
that I made the GRIN
with a cubic dependence
of the index of refraction,
another quadratic.
Then this is the question I
would have arrived instead.
Now I cannot cancel r anymore.
So it means that each ray goes
to a different focal point.
So therefore, this
element does not focus.
So this would not
be a good lens.
Actually, the cubic
dependence has
some other interesting
properties,
but these are perhaps for
a more advanced class.
Nevertheless, the
quadratic dependence
is very convenient
because as you can see,
it drops out of here.
It means that I have
a unique focal length
at which all the
rays focus, at least
in the paraxial approximation.
So that is the story
of the quadratic GRIN,
how it comes about, and how
we derive its focal length.
And I should also say that
even though my derivation here
was cheating,
basically the way I
cheated is I assumed that d,
the thickness of the lens,
is also very small.
So it is very similar to
the thin lens approximation.
Nevertheless, this equation
is actually true, even
for thicker lenses.
So that's kind of interesting.
OK.
The second way people make
GRIN optics is actually
a combination of
melding and grinding.
And the way they do that
results in a different profile
that now the index of refraction
varies along the longitudinal--
the axial dimension.
So what does this mean?
What they do first is
they start with a stack
of glasses of different
indices over refraction.
So here and in the rest of this
lecture, the sort of darkness
indicates index of refraction.
So dark gray means high index.
Light gray means low index.
So they stack them.
Then they meld them,
which basically
means that they mold and meld.
So after they meld
them, basically
the index of refraction,
the variation
becomes kind of continuous
because as they meld,
the different indices will
kind of diffuse into each.
So you will get a
quasi-continuous variational
index.
And the final thing they
do is they actually polish.
This stack that they've got with
a continuous index variation,
they polish it.
So now this thing actually
has two properties.
First of all, it is a lens
in a traditional sense
because it has a spherical
surface, so it focuses
by virtue of refraction.
But in addition, it has
an axial index profile.
So here the
motivation is actually
a little bit different than what
Pepe and I described earlier.
So clearly I did not end up
with a slab-looking element.
I still have a curvature.
But the motivation is different.
It's a little bit similar to--
in the previous
lecture I think we
mentioned something called the
Smith correction or the Smith
telescope.
So it's a very
similar motivation.
If you take a
uniform index sphere,
we saw this a couple of
times that in general, this
produces an aberrated image,
even if it is oriented
properly.
This is supposed to be a
plane or convex lens oriented
in the correct way.
That is the plane wave goes
with the spherical surface.
But still, this
does not completely
cancel the aberration.
There is still some residue.
So what do you do then, if you
modify the index of refraction
in the interior of the surface,
what happens is this ray--
let's take the
paraxial ray over here.
It hits at a relatively high
index, whereas this ray,
it hits at a
relatively lower index.
What this means,
if you want to look
at it from the geometrical
optics point of view--
there's also a wave optics point
of view that is interesting,
but from the geometrical
optics point of view,
it means that the
Snell's law of refraction
here will be milder for
this ray than for this ray.
Therefore, this ray, who's
used to focus kind of violently
and produce a spherical
aberration here,
now it will be pulled outwards.
And therefore, it
will be forced to go
through the proper focal point
over here as the paraxial lens.
So this is a clever way to
fix spherical aberration.
And I don't know who
invented this first.
I believe-- and maybe, Colin,
you again correct with this.
I believe in was Duncan
Moore at the Rochester
who came up with
this particular--
at least I've seen
a paper of his
which is as old as
I am, 1971, that
discusses this optimization.
So in order to solve the
basic principles of GRINs,
I would like to spend
a little bit of time--
I don't think
we'll finish today.
We'll probably have to leak into
next Wednesday after the quiz.
But I'll get us started on, how
do we properly compute things
like index?
I mean, like focal length for
a gradient index structure.
So we'd like to ask the
question more generally.
If I have a medium whose
index of refraction
varies as a function
of position.
So here, this cloud is meant
to indicate a variable index.
So you have high index, low
index, in different positions.
So this is like a
generalized GRIN if you wish.
We saw two types.
You saw quadratic
and you saw axial.
But it could be really--
in principle, I should be
able to fabricate something
like this.
Not that it is readily
doable, but let's
consider it for
the sake of value.
So you've seen this
diagram before.
In fact, I copied this
from an earlier slide.
One of the previous--
I think it was in the first
lecture or second lecture.
So we don't know
really what path
a ray will follow through
these variable index medium,
but we know one thing.
We know that if you integrate
this quantity, if you integrate
the index of refraction
times the length,
the elemental length
along the path of the ray,
we know that Fermat requires
that these quantities will
be minimized.
So how do we deal with that?
I mean, what can
we do about this?
Now, some of you who have taken
advanced mechanics classes,
this sounds a
little bit familiar.
What is the name that
comes to mind when you
see this kind of expression?
So let me repeat again.
I have a situation
where something--
in this case, a
light ray, but it
could be something
else, a particle
or some mechanical analogy--
can follow a number of
different trajectories.
It can go this way or it can go
this way or this way and so on.
To give you another
sort of trivial example,
if I drop my marker here,
it goes down straight.
So you may have wondered, well,
why does it go down straight?
Why does it not do
something like this
or like this or whatever?
Why does it not go
up, for that matter?
Well, it goes straight because--
well, because gravity
pulls it down right.
Well, we're very
happy with that.
We know from experience
that things fall straight.
But we also know that
gravity does not always
produce straight trajectories.
For example, the Earth.
Thankfully, the Earth
follows a circular,
or actually elliptical,
trajectory around the sun.
And that's very fortunate
because if the Earth had a way
to escape from the sun,
then we would all be--
we would not even exist.
So we know that gravity can
produce straight trajectories.
It can produce
elliptical trajectories,
hyperbolical trajectories,
and so on and so forth.
So there's more to it
than the straight falling
of the apple in Newton's case
or of the marker in my case.
So anyway, so the reason
I'm giving all this preamble
is because this may
be familiar for you
from the field of mechanics.
And the buzzword
that comes to mind
when you have this kind of
integral with something inside
and you demand that the
integral itself is maximized
is Lagrangian.
It is the Lagrangian principle
that you may have seen.
I don't think those of
you took 2003 saw it.
Did you or did
you not, actually?
I don't know.
Is anybody in the
class who took 2003?
You should because
2004 is a prerequisite.
And as a principle,
if you are here,
it means you have taken
both 2003 and 2004.
We have lost our undergraduates,
or they lost their voice,
or they're too sleepy.
Anyway.
Or there's another
possibility, that we
don't remember if we were
taught Lagrangians in 2003.
Anyway.
But I will not do it this way.
So it turns out I can solve
this problem using a Lagrangian
formulation.
But I will not do it this way.
Did someone want to speak?
I saw the camera moving.
Was someone about to speak?
AUDIENCE: I was just
going to say, yes,
we did have Lagrangian.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Ah, you did.
OK.
Thank you.
Well, even if you did,
I guess I will not
do it with the Lagrangians
because, well, the math is
too complicated and would
kind of cause a detour here.
Nevertheless, I will use
a mechanical analogy.
So for a moment, we'll
take a break from optics.
And I guess to
justify why 2004 is
a prerequisite for this
class, I will show this.
And I will spend, I guess,
the next 15 or so minutes
to establish a connection
between this mechanical system
and light rays.
For now, let's forget
about light rays.
I've given you-- it's
actually a particle.
So it looks like a car
but it's really small.
So I don't have to worry
about moments of inertia
and all of that stuff.
It is also frictionless, so
I don't have any dissipation
at all in the system.
This particle is
attached to a rigid--
to an immobile, rigid
wall with a spring.
And basically what
I can do is I can
inject some energy into the
particles by pulling it.
So if I do that, then
we know that this system
has two forms of energy.
When I actually pull
it, what I do is I
store energy in the spring.
The spring is not happy
having its energy stored.
It will want to give it away.
What does it mean to
give away the energy?
It means to convert
it to kinetic.
It means the spring will start
pulling the particle back.
As the particle is pulled
back, it will accelerate.
It will reach a
maximum velocity--
we know that from
classical mechanics--
approximately where the
spring has zero displacement.
And at this point,
all of the energy
has been converted to kinetic.
And of course it will not stop
there because it is moving,
and there's nothing to stop it.
It will keep moving.
But if it moves,
now it is beginning
to push, to squeeze this spring.
So now the particle is
giving back its energy
into the spring until all of
the energy has been given.
Now the spring is squeezed.
Doesn't like to be squeezed.
It starts giving energy
back to the particle.
And of course, on
and on they go.
This will execute and
oscillate in motion
forever because I
neglected all dissipation.
And of course, what is
happening in this case is
that at any given moment, the
particle will have a mix--
the system will have a mix
of kinetic energy and energy
stored into the spring,
which is referred
to as potential energy.
So of course, the kinetic
energy is given by 1/2 times
the mass times the
velocity squared.
If you remember the
definition of momentum,
momentum equals
mass times velocity.
So I can also
write it like this.
Momentum squared over
2 times the mass.
And the potential energy--
actually, the potential energy
can have very different forms
depending on what is exactly
the energy storage element.
In the case of a spring--
actually, in the case of a
hook spring, a linear spring,
it is simply equal to the
square of the displacement
of the spring with respect
to its rest position.
So anyway, no matter
what these things are,
the sum must be
constant because, again,
energy cannot be gained
or lost by its system.
So the sum of the potential
and kinetic energy
is always conserved.
So that is one thing,
and it's very good.
Now, let me play a game.
So first of all, I
will write the energy.
I will basically repeat
what is on the slide.
I will repeat it on
the whiteboard here.
So let me write the energy.
I will write it in a funny way.
I will write it as a function of
the momentum p and the position
q.
And now, in the
previous slide, these
were actually scalar quantities
because this thing moves only
along a straight line.
But in general, of course, I
can have positions and momenta
that are vectors.
So I switched to
vector notation.
I hope that doesn't
confuse you horribly.
So let me write it down.
So in the vector case, this
will equal the momentum vector
divided by 2m plus 1/2 m--
wait a minute.
1/2 k, the spring constant,
times the position vector
square.
Now what I'm going
to do, for fun,
is I'm going to take derivatives
of this quantity with respect
to the position
and the momentum.
Of course, since
these became vectors,
now these are not
exactly derivatives,
they are gradients.
So basically what I will do is
I will compute the gradient of H
with respect to p.
This is a matter of notation.
I will denote it as dH dp.
So what is dH dp?
Well, what I have to do
is I have to compute--
clearly this term does not play
because it only depends on q.
But this term
contains the momentum.
So if I do it, it will
actually-- you can do it.
It is actually p times its--
p over m.
That's it.
Nothing else.
And then I'm going to do
the same with respect to q.
And I'm going to call it dH dq.
Again, it is a gradient
with respect to q.
And for the same reasons
as the other one,
it will turn out
to be k times 2.
OK.
Then again for fun--
I'm not justifying
what I'm doing.
It's just coming sort of some--
coming out of some
sort of epiphany.
I will write down two
differential equations.
One of them, I will
write this one.
It is already on
your screen there.
dq dt.
What is that?
That's the time derivative
of the displacement.
Therefore, it is the velocity.
So we'll take it to be equal
to the gradient of the quantity
H of the energy, that we called
it H for some strange reason,
with respect to the
opposite variable.
This was the derivative of q.
I will take its gradient
with respect to p.
And let's see what I get.
This way I get p over m.
That's correct.
Actually, this equation is
not particularly insightful.
This is the definition
of momentum, isn't it?
If you recall-- this means
recall, like in cartoons.
The little cloud.
The momentum is defined
as m times dq dt.
That's the definition
of momentum.
So by doing this
trick, by taking
the gradient of the energy
with respect to the momentum
and setting it equal to the
velocity, I got a true result.
I got a result that
happens to be true.
Now let's see if I can
pull the opposite trick.
If I can take the
derivative with respect
to time of the momentum, that's
like an acceleration quantity
because momentum is velocity.
So its derivative
is acceleration.
And let's see if I can
get away by putting
it equal to the derivative
of this quantity H
with respect to
the other variable.
In this case, I cannot
quite get away with it.
I have to put a minus sign.
And what do I get if
I put a minus sign?
kq.
What's this now?
kq?
It is k times displacement.
So what are the units of Hooke's
constant time displacement?
Force.
What is on the left-hand side?
OK.
I said acceleration.
Actually, I should
have corrected myself,
and I should have said,
proportional to acceleration.
This is the derivative
of the momentum.
So therefore, it is force.
So what is this then,
the equation that I got?
It is the force balance on the--
it is Newton's law,
actually, on the particle.
It says that the force
pulling the particle,
it is the restoring
force due to the spring.
And what are the two
equations combined?
Actually, the two
equations combined,
they are what we call
the equations of motion.
The equations of
motion, by definition,
are first order
differential equations
that link the dynamical
variables that
is the position, the
displacement, and the velocity.
So this is what I did.
I got a set of
differential equations
that link the displacement
to the momentum-- that
is the velocity.
And again, the derivative of
the displacement back to the--
I'm sorry, the derivative
of the velocity,
the derivative of the momentum,
back to the displacement
itself.
So if you look at it, if
you omit this middle part,
if you look at it like
this, these are simply--
as I said, these are
the equations of motion.
If you look at this part
over here, this is of course
a more general result. That's
why I bothered to do it.
And this is where the
connection to optics
will come from next week.
This set of equations
is called Hamiltonian.
And I will put in
brackets "canonical."
I don't particularly
like this term.
But anyway, some people use it.
Hamiltonian canonical equations.
So the point, then, which
I will say just this,
and then I will stop
and continue next time,
the point is that this is now
a much more general property.
Even though I showed that it
is true for the specific case
of a mass spring
system without damper--
I showed that to be true.
But this is a more
general property
for any dynamical system that
has a conserved quantity.
So in the case of the
mechanical system,
the conserved
quantity is energy.
If this conserved
quantity can be
written as a function of
the dynamical variables,
in this case, of the mechanical
system position and momentum--
OK.
So I started a long sentence.
Let me close my sentence.
So if a dynamical system
has a conserved quantity,
then I can write down a set
of Hamiltonian equations
for this dynamical
system in terms
of the gradients of
this conserved quantity.
And that will be the
equations of motion.
OK.
So what we will
do then next time
is we will actually
show, in almost one
to one analogy, that--
oh, and by the way,
this conserved quantity
that we called it energy in the
case of the mechanical system,
in general it's called
the Hamiltonian.
So H itself is the Hamiltonian.
So what we'll do next
is we will actually
show we can derive a Hamiltonian
for rays for an optical system.
And of course, when we write
equations of motion for rays,
we'll get the ray trajectories.
Therefore, we will be
able to ray tracing.
And the reason
this is interesting
because the potential
actually will turn out
to be the index of refraction.
And in the same way,
the potential here,
if you go back to my equation--
the potential turned out to
be a function of position.
In the gradient index optics
that we mentioned just now,
the index of refraction
is a function of position.
So we will see that in the
case of the GRIN element,
the index of refraction actually
has the role of a potential.
And it is this potential
that draws the--
very similar to gravity.
The potential that
draws the sun--
I mean, that draws the Earth to
rotate around the sun and not
the other way around.
The same way the
potential draws the Earth
to rotate around the
sun, it is a similar,
or I should say analogous,
kind of potential
that draws rays inwards
in a GRIN element
and causes them to focus.
So we'll pick up
on that next time.
And obviously, don't worry
about this for the quiz.
So I'm not crazy.
So yeah.
So we'll properly conclude
this topic next time.
It will be next week's homework.